in real life
you can sometimes get away with some
pretty heinous [ __ ]
in the world of video games though it's
difficult to keep things
under wraps when thousands of people are
watching
the consequences for such bad public
behavior
can range from a slap on the wrist to
career-ending
permanent bans as some of the people on
today's list found out
here are the top 10 banned players
kicking off our list is xqc who was no
stranger to disciplinary action
he's been suspended from and fined by
the overwatch league but it was his
behavior during a
league of legends stream that finally
introduced him
to the pleasures of being permanently
banned
i have really really really bad news
eight months less than three
[Music]
oh my god
and this particular band was just one of
many
most recently xqc was banned from twitch
for seven
days and from all twitch rivals events
for six
months after he was accused of stream
sniping during a game of four guys
dr lupo shroud and tyler juan all
weighed in
on the recent ban it doesn't deserve to
get permaban
bro no [ __ ] he got banned he street
sniped out stream i i'd say they made
the right decision
uh i did mention in the past though
getting banned doesn't really mean
anything
right one guy in one game got ahead of
me
and in the heat of the moment i didn't
realize that he was probably also a
stream sniper
and he backed off to throw so that i
could get the crown so that was the
reason that he streamed stream signed is
to counteract
you know for content that i got handed
free win
i i've done a lot of bad things and i
haven't been a bunch of times
but i've never given up
and ninth pick leagues i will dominate
was so toxic that he got banned from the
lcs for an
entire year early on in his career and
many people thought that was the
end for him i know when i got banned
everyone just wrote me off they're like
all right well he only played for a year
if he's banned for a year
he's just never coming back in the end i
decided that it'd probably be better for
me like just fight my way back and just
prove
to everyone that i could do it why will
dominate claude his way back to the
top of the ladder on a different account
while he waited for his competitive band
to be lifted
the results of his grind showed once he
was back on the lcs stage
and later on he also found success as a
streamer he's had an
incredible amount of success you know
his shows on the crackdown
and his uh rebroadcasting of the lcs i
mean he's
insane viewership his youtube channel is
growing like crazy
more recently i will dominate was
suspended from the lol partner program
for 12 months
after riot games decided a few of his
comments on stream violated their
policies
a move condemned by the community
including locodoco
it has his entire livelihood running on
it and
yeah it's really shitty that riot did
ban him and they're not
willing to have an open dialogue about
it just let us know why let dom know why
so if he needs to change that he can
change
as devastating as the ban is i will
dominate has no plans to step away from
content creation
i will continue to like do lcs at lec
related content because i'm
passionate about it coming in at number
eight we have solo
before he won a whole bunch of dota 2
majors
a ton of money and the mercedes benz
solo was banned for
throwing a match for 322 bucks
with three seconds solo as well they
just went in here today
what's up with that that's not good no
one
really knew how to deal with match
fixing in dota back in the day
so even though starladder initially
banned solo
and the rest of his team for life an
apology from the culprit was enough for
them to lift the sanctions
as the years went on solo redeemed
himself as the captain of virtus pro
one of the most successful teams in dota
2's history
on to the back of the ogre gets tapped
into battle hunger will chase him back
to fountain
a triple kill for solo some way somehow
this man is a monster
look for more get a ball it's an ultra
killer give him the rampage
come on no so long kill him rampage
he gets it for the 3-2-2 meme that gets
spammed in twitch chat anytime
someone makes a suspiciously bad play
will forever remind solo and the rest of
us
the mistakes of his youth zai wants to
jump on the shield
he needs to keep it so close there's the
shield damage jump forward
he backed up five hp and the cat
well there's one of his nine lives
landing in the number seven spot is
jensen it was once permabanned by a riot
due to an ongoing history
of being a dick back when he was known
as incarnation
jensen and a few of his teammates had
all their current and
future accounts banned for alleged ddos
activity
abusive behavior and poor sportsmanship
as jensen told lolly sports in this clip
we were a pretty strong strong team i'd
say but unfortunately we got
disqualified as a team and a few members
of the team
including me got banned due to toxic
behavior
jensen stayed on his absolute best
behavior for the next couple of years
grinding solo queue and coaching sk
gaming in 2015 he became the first
permaban pro to be reinstated he then
joined cloud nine and later
team liquid where he is considered one
of the best mid laners in na
jensen gets the double kill that's the
stair misses there's the equalizer on
cooldown
sneaking kicks it back as ray goes down
and apex
[Applause]
infamous cheetah forsaken who was caught
red-handed
at extremes land 2018 asia finals
during a game the tournament admins
realized forsaken was playing a little
too well and decided to take a closer
look at his pc
and it's going to be a b splitting
towards bomb site so they react
accordingly for staple would pop flash
into maine and he's gonna get three
frags crazy guy fog and jason all
dropping he'll get the fourth as well
great work from forsaken forsaking old
caution
optics rifler was running a cheap
program in the background
he tried to cover it up by renaming the
file word.exe
and then fighting with admins while he
tried to delete it from his computer
optic india was then disqualified from
the tournament and eventually
disbanded as for forsaken himself not
only was he officially
banned from participating in any esports
related activities for
five years but after receiving
numerous threats from disgruntled csgo
fans had to get off social media
completely
nowadays all the remains of forsaken is
the meme
i did who put word exe on who's the
balls to do that on lamp i know
and number five pick is a popular
fortnite content creator
faze jarvis or rather that's what he was
before he was banned from fortnite
forever
after uploading a video of himself using
an aimbot in game
so you guys can see on my screen i've
definitely got the hacks you can see
where people are going for some reason
it doesn't show on streamlabs obs but
let's just run it
now the thing is jarvis wasn't using his
main
fortnite account or even his pc to play
and he wasn't trying to win a tournament
or do anything to compromise the
competitive integrity of the game
he just wanted to show his viewers what
using an aimbot was like
and having a little bit of fun while
doing it jabba's his downfall
i was uploading the videos to youtube
and it wasn't long before he realized
just how big of a mess he got himself
into it's obvious that i made a massive
mistake
and of course i would never think about
doing anything like this again
you know when i was making those videos
i never thought about
the consequence and i never thought
about the consequences that could happen
from me making those videos i just
thought about
i just thought about entertaining you
guys that tearful apology video has
since
amassed nearly 20 million views
and jarvis's channel has almost doubled
in size since the incident
so i think it's safe to say he's doing
all right he even made a whole
music video about the ordeal
making videos and it's crazy i just got
one question
how i get banned from my game
anna before entry is blitzchang one of
the top hearthstone players
in the asia pacific region who decided
to support a political cause on stream
and it cost him when so many people are
protesting out there and i just
i just sit there and then play my
tournaments i just feel kind of bad and
i want to do something during an
interview he gave after his last game in
the 2019 hearthstone asia pacific grand
masters tournament
blitz chung donned a gas mask and dark
goggles
emulating hong kong's street protesters
and shouting
liberate hong kong revolution of our
times
at the end of the segment
blizzard ruled the players conduct
violated their rules
and banned blitzchang from participating
in blizzard esports events for a
year blitzchang also told the media that
his tournament winnings of approximately
ten
thousand dollars were taken away as a
result but what blizzard didn't
anticipate was the public
outrage their decision brought down upon
them the message
was loud and clear blizzard
had let down its community blizzard reps
apologized
gave back the prize money and reduced
blizzchang's ban
to six months but they maintained the
political statements have
no place on their official broadcast we
didn't live
up to the high standards that we really
set for ourselves
and the second is we failed in our
purpose
and for that i am sorry and i accept
accountability
number three is league's original rage
streamer
tyler1
after years of what riot called quote a
well-documented history of account bans
for verbal abuse
end quote they ruled that all of
tyler1's
future accounts would be banned on site
riot went as far as calling him a quote
genuine
jerk not that he seemed too upset about
it from the looks of the parody tribute
he made for himself
alright guys signing out gonna miss you
man
later boys now instead of getting mad
tyler1 decided to get
busy in 2017 he founded his own
independent lol twitch tournament
called the tyler1 championship series
oh my god oh my god it's a dragon
and in 2018 riot decided to lift his ban
on the condition that his active
accounts be clean of abusive behavior
nearly 400 000 people tuned in to watch
tyler1's
first post banned stream god damn
it's been a minute since i've seen
myself on camera you guys are
truly blessed to have me here
number two on our list is the most high
profile band in
rainbow six siege history shaika
has been banned from any esl competitive
play for two years
the any money any winnings that t b
genius has
accumulated throughout this season has
been forfeited as well as their spot in
this season of the pro league scheiker
and his
godlike skills came under attack after
he was accused of cheating in a pro
match
i wrecked him he cried
the official investigation found nothing
amiss but the anti-cheat software
found he was pressing his four key at
quote
inhuman speeds as a result he was issued
a
two-year ban and had to endure an
endless stream of ridicule yeah i'm
playing shaco my game
the biggest shooter in the game while
it's still unclear whether schaiko
actually cheated or not his story has a
happy ending
schreiko's ban was lifted early and he
returned to the competitive scene
to dominate the competition so it's
shiko in a 1v2
second has his position been spotted yes
it has he gets derpe but it's only one
second left on the diffuser
and it's the most infamous member of bds
a topic was involved in one of the
biggest match fixing scandals in the
history of esports it's brax he
along with the rest of i buy power
through a match at sibo season five
and it's very weird to see steel opting
over skadoodle
i don't know if skadool is not feeling
it right now or what is going on but i
buy power is definitely not playing
like i buy power when the scandal came
to light valve dished out indefinite
bans
to pretty much the entire roster
effectively ending the career of one of
na's most
promising prodigies many people thought
brax's punishment was
way too harsh and csgo talents like
semmler and fallen had a lot to say on
the subject
i think it's a very sad history that he
can't compete anymore for me it's a
little bit too harsh
for what happened and for being the
first time it ever happened
and i'm just so sad that you [ __ ]
brought swagging this [ __ ] with you
that you took advantage of a young star
that was that had everything ahead of
him
and that he could he could have gone on
to become one of the best north american
players of all time
to dominate worldwide and you ruined
that luckily
years later a new and exciting fps came
along and brax became the first
former cs gopro to switch to valorant
one enemy remaining
so did the punishments fit the crime
have you ever had an account banned
before tell us your best banned stories
and don't forget
to subscribe to the channel we are on
the road to
two million subs and you can help us get
there thanks for watching guys and i'll
see you all again soon
i was once i was once barred from going
into a club at university
because there were too many too many
guys in there
that's what the bouncer said he didn't
use that language specifically he used
something that i
i probably can't say on camera but um
okay yeah that was
that was pretty shocking yeah so what he
actually said
was sorry mate there's too much sausage
in there already